so Tiffany we love crowdfunding
crowdfunded for our own film and we love
the the benefits that go with it but
we're curious do you think that
crowdfunding might be ruining social
media just a tad here's a scenario often
what happens is a week before someone
launches a campaign we find they get
friendly with us social me it was just
great two weeks later that's wise yeah
they have a social media campaign which
is great we want people to come to us
but we're wondering are there dark sides
of it because we've known people that
have actually several acquaintances over
the fact that the support for their
crowdfunding campaign ilysm what they
hoped it would be Wow from others now so
what are some of the solutions so that
we can still spread our message via
Twitter or Facebook that's a great
question asking questions was all about
authenticity you know like are your
intentions in the right place when
you're you know they are they connecting
with you because they then want to ask
you for something but you could be
helping an artist so why is that bad
okay I don't think they're crowdfunding
is running social media I think that's
not happening I think it's crowdfunding
is like the most exciting thing that's
happened in film financing since I've
been alive just to Ma critized how
people can get funded and it's beautiful
support and I love it that people i mean
when i talked about solely spray and I
think my big fear was this expectation
of money in return but when people give
on Kickstarter IndieGoGo they're just
giving as they want to support you which
is beautiful and now all my thought of
my films my new phones are funded
through grants and it's such a beautiful
way to create is not to feel this you
know pressure but I asked to have a film
that has investors and we are going to
be paying them back and that feels
really good too so but anyways back to
crowdfunding because i don't think it's
burning social media but i do hear you
on what people's motives are but i
thought that's always the case i mean
you could say that that was
like people they knew that Uncle Joe has
a lot of money and a really nice Uncle
Joe and then they asked uncle joe to
fund their movie I mean it's just an
easier way to do it so um I always look
at it is when you let people funny movie
you're giving them an opportunity to be
involved in something really exciting so
I never look at it as they're taking
something for you but they're letting
you be a part of something cool and
exciting so but i but i do think it is
exposing you know these tools that you
know you know can't do it you know the
thing with social media is it's an
extension of us and we are both good and
bad we have good intentions we have bad
intentions and it is all just as people
talk about technology as if it's this
other thing it's us we couldn't see far
enough we invented a telescope we wanted
to communicate with more people we
invented the internet I mean we as
humans it's just tendrils to us and
we're all the spectrum of good and bad
so it's just it's just extending and
amplifying that do you see any dark side
of crowdfunding or you see it all as a
very positive way no then you know it's
funny we have not crowdfunder the film
because you know it's interesting we
asked our community to do a lot of stuff
for us like we make these films where we
ask them to be in it like they are new
films these cloud films we have them
record themselves they send us videos we
edit it so we focus on different things
that we're asking for a community of it
that doesn't anyone I'm excited when we
first try it I think it's a really cool
thing to do because you're everyone's
getting involved in something which I'm
very into but I don't I don't see the
dark sides but I haven't crowd funded a
project yet so maybe ask me that
question after I've tried it is that
what cloud sourcing is then no actually
we use the reason why we call it cloud
filmmaking is we wanted to get away from
the word of the cloud the crowd because
to us crowd kind of to me feels like a
crowd like a mass of people but when I
when we make this cloud film we call
that we wrote a cloud filmmaking
manifesto
and the whole concept of these films is
no we read script we're still directing
it into one movie I'm directing it but
we invite people all over the world so
our first one so our first one we wrote
a one-minute script called a declaration
of interdependence we invited people
around the world to send us videos of
themselves reading it or artwork based
on the script and then we edit and got
entries from all over the world we
edited it together to a 4 minute film
and then the critical part of crowd
filmmaking cloud filmmaking to us is
inviting them to further participate so
we asked them to help us translate it so
that film was translated into 65
languages in six weeks and then we offer
free customized versions of that movie
to any nonprofit working to make the
world better so for a declaration of
interdependence we've already made 100
free versions of it and then we have
this new film engage where we ask people
to put their hands on the heart and feel
it beating and think about what that
meant and then we edited that into a new
film called engage just release that and
right now we're making tons of free
versions and this is all through a grant
and then our third cloud film is called
brain power from neurons to networks and
it looks at the parallels between early
childhood brain development and the
global development of the internet and
that we asked people even more to
contribute so we're so it's interesting
like so we call it cloud sourcing
creativity because we're asking them to
make a movie with us but someday we'll
also ask them to fund something with us
you